Ummm? Hello?
What the hell is this?!
I'm asking myself the same question
literally no this this can't be
happening this...what are you
doing here? well I'll tell you that when
you tell me where here is? Cosplay? oh
do you want a selfie brom, sorry we're not
no I'm also the flash those are the what?
the flash? flash flash? it's complicated make
I like your outfit it seems like a comfy
your's is  pretty cool you safe and
breathable..I'm Barry Allen. no what does
that mean?! this should be impossible now
it should be impossible NOW?! you don't know
about the... oh my god don't do this to me
I don't know about the what?! are you okay?
I told Victor this was possible...
What does this mean?!
welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is going to be my video all
about the crisis on Infinite Earths
Ezra Miller scene and the flash
flashpoint movie because there's a lot
of stuff going on and here obviously
there canonizing this - the arrow verse
saying that all the Justice League movie
characters exists in an alternate
reality but we just got a bunch of new
details about the flash movie so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the easter-egg videos we're doing a
flash ring giveaway we have two versions
of the flash here they're going to
introduce the flash ring during the
flash movie so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from this crossover
scene on the video so they start this
off by having that funny moment of
Oliver Queen
bopping Barry on the forehead making him
think that he has unlocked his potential
when really it's meant to be more of a
pep talk Barry is as powerful as he's
always been so he goes around the
speedforce collecting all the Paragons
in Oliver Queen's consciousness from
important moments in their lives because
the Speed Force is this nexus of
space-time where time moves very
differently and you sort of create
mental constructs of your own realities
wherever you want to be he takes a wrong
turn and winds up running into the Ezra
Miller flash from Justice League inside
a version of STAR Labs but it's filmed
as if it's happening inside the Justice
League movie universe of the DC EU I
talked about this on Twitter some of you
may have noticed this it's the only
scene from any of the crossover episodes
that's filmed in anamorphic movie ratio
so it's filmed as if it's happening
inside a movie the movie universe of the
Justice League movie the reason they did
this is to imply that our Barry had
traveled into a moment from the Ezra
Miller Flash's life so it's our Barry
running into Ezra Miller it's not as
Room Miller's Barry running into our
Barry so whatever was happening before
this moment Ezra Miller's flash just
happened to be inside the Speed Force
which is why he didn't get wiped because
at the end of their little crossover
moment he says they shouldn't even be
possible because as he's fading out
Barry is trying to tell him about crisis
on Infinite Earths and the fact that the
entire multiverse just got wiped by the
antimatter wave the Speed Force protects
them all from being white because it
exists outside of space-time that's why
all the Paragons
survive the antimatter way because they
were thrown into the speedforce by all
of her out of the vanishing point the
funny thing about this though is that
even though this is meant to be the
movie version of star lapse it looks
exactly like the TV show version of STAR
Labs and obviously should go without
saying that when they do get to the
flash movie his version of STAR Labs
will look different than this but they
had their funny introduction our Barry
has met alternate versions of the flash
before and alternate versions of himself
but until now they've all looked like
him that's the main reason why he's so
confused like this shouldn't even be
possible
why are you doing here the second reason
is because they're acknowledging the
meta aspect of having the movie
characters crossover with the TV
characters which usually is something
that you say is never going to happen
like it's super super rare to see that
happen in the case of like Clark Gregg
in the Marvel Universe he's one of the
few people that's gone back and forth
between the TV shows in the movies
samuel l.jackson did it but so far they
haven't really done that in a big way
with the DC movie characters at least
the current ones right now they also do
this to shine a light on some of the
drama that happened way back in 2014
when they first announced Ezra Miller so
there was a hot minute when they were
airing the first episodes of the flash
TV show way back in 2014 right around
that same time they announced Ezra
Miller as the movie flash everyone felt
really weird about it because we're like
wait a minute
we thought Grant Gustin was the flash is
he not going to be the movie flash if then
eventually Ezra Miller and Grant Gustin
both came out and said that there are
total Broz they don't care about any of
that drama stuff so they don't have any
kind of beef between the two of them and
Marc Guggenheim the showrunner on arrow
and the lead writer on the crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover revealed it
was actually Warner Brothers movie
studio people that asked the arrowverse
people to put Ezra Miller in the
crossover not the other way around you
think the TV show people will be the
ones trying to get the movie characters
they did reach out to Michael Keaton Val
Kilmer or a bunch of other Batman movie
actors but the movie people called them
and said please find a spot for Ezra
Miller
they had already wrapped this episode
the arrow episode but they were like
hell yeah we can find a spot for Ezra
Miller so they brought in a bunch of
extra people on a separate day to film
this scene and then tag it on after
they'd already done the episode the joke
about Ezra Miller's Barry Allen not
knowing that he's called the flash is
just because they never called him the
flash officially during the DC movies
that he appear
Batman V Superman Justice League Suicide
Squad they'll give him the flash name
officially during the flash movie which
they did confirm was going to be a version
of flashpoint I'll explain what's going
on with that in a second because a lot
of people have asked wait a minute does
that mean that Grant Gustin is going to get
to cross over into the flashpoint movie
now as some sort of cameo add to that
they might not even premiere the
flashpoint movie until after the flash
TV show has ended its run so keep in
mind that it's still going to be a couple
years before we see the flashpoint movie
they joke about each other's flash suits
the joke about Ezra Miller's flash suit
is that it looks cool but it's super
uncomfortable to wear it doesn't breathe
well and it's a bit awkward to walk
around in
that's why Ezra Miller's flash says all
those things about Grant Gustin suit oh
wow it looks so comfy in the joke
obviously then about grant gustin's
flash costume is that it doesn't look
nearly as cool as Ezra Miller's flash
suit they will give Ezra Miller a new
version of the flash shoot during the
flashpoint movie because I think the
idea is is that that movie's successful
they'll do sequels and in each new movie
you typically give the hero a new
version of a costume to sell way more
toys his new flash suit will probably be
a little less hardcore in a little more
comic book accurate the other reason why
is Remillard flash is so confused and
weirded out by this moment is because he
hasn't learned about the existence of
the multiverse and hasn't met alternate
versions of himself yet he has travelled
through time though they did have that
time-travel moment during Batman vs
Superman they were going to pay that off
during one of the Justice League sequels
they had planned but that was when
Justice League was going to be a trilogy of
movies I've already done a couple videos
about what the story of that trilogy was
going to be it was going to play out very
similarly to Avengers infinity war in
Avengers end game the dialogue that he
fades out on is I told Victor this was
possible referencing Victor stone aka
cyborg meaning that he and cyborg at
some point had a conversation about the
possibility that there was a multiverse
and he could theoretically meet
alternate versions of himself it also
kind of makes me believe that they're
going to have a cyborg cameo during the
flashpoint movie but this is them
canonizing the movie characters to the
arrowverse multiverse just saying that
all that stuff that henry cavill
Superman Ben Affleck's Batman all that
stuff happened in an alternate universe
somewhere getting to the flash
flashpoint movie stuff so they're
supposed to film that sometime next year
I believe after as
Miller finishes making the next
fantastic Beast movie even if you don't
care about the fantastic beast franchise
Warner Brothers cares more about it from
a financial standpoint because the Harry
Potter franchise has been more reliable
for them than the DC movie franchise
Ezra Miller is playing a main character
during those fantastic beast movies
that's why they're doing that movie
first then they're doing the flash movie
Warner Brothers has changed his overall
strategy and how it connects each of the
different movies but the movies that are
set in present-day after the events of
Justice League are mostly still loosely
connected but some will not reference
the other movies in really big ways like
the Aquaman movie only loosely
referenced the events of Justice League
but you didn't have any really big
Justice League crossover characters the
flashpoint movie will probably have a
few cameos but they're not going to do the
exact plot of comic book flashpoint with
all the Justice League characters like
Wonder Woman Batman Superman I am really
hoping for a ben affleck batman cameo of
some kind even a small one because
jeffrey dean morgan who played thomas
wayne during Batman V Superman recently
said that it was time to put on a mask
again and said several times in the past
that he would love to play flashpoint
Batman in a heartbeat right now the
director of the flash movie is Andy
machete he's the person that did both of
the it movies so we love that a horror
director is doing the flash movie so
maybe there'll be some good scares
during the flashpoint reality that Ezra
Miller's Barrie creates by saving his
mother they haven't announced who their
movie version of the reverse flash is
going to be they probably won't cast him
till next year so I'll say Anthony star
would be an amazing reverse flash you
all know him as home Lander from the
boys TV show
he plays a fantastic psychopath
gentlemen
if the flash flashpoint movie does real
well I think the probe for a trilogy and
any big Justice League crossovers that
they don't do in the first movie they
can always do in the sequels so let me
know in the comments if the movie
version of flashpoint will be smaller
what do you want them to do with the
sequels and who do you want them to cast
as reverse flash in the movies there was
a brand new flash episode 10 trailer for
the post-crisis universe I'll do a video
for that sometime in the next couple of
days but leave all your requests and big
questions in the comments
congratulations Anthony Lockhart you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my full crisis
crisis on Infinite Earths videos and click here
for my new spider-man Morbius trailer
and sinister six teaser thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!